We are back with
an exclusive investigation.
CNN has uncovered evidence
that the Russian mercenary group,
Wagner, is complicit
in the prolonged
deadly fighting in Sudan.
By supplying Sudan's rapid support force.
It's a paramilitary group
also known as the RC F.
About 2 million
people have left Sudan since mid-April.
As the country's
humanitarian crisis grows
more dire by the day.
And although
the RCF denies links to Wagner
and any involvement in mass rape, CNN
verified incidents of rape
perpetuated by the RCF, including one
captured on video
in the face of the RSPs.
Repeated denials.
We feel
it is important to broadcast
part of that graphic
and disturbing video.
CNN's Nima Elbagir
has this exclusive report.
The fighting on the streets
of Sudan is relentless.
Ceasefire after a ceasefire
has not held
forces previously accused of genocide.
Returning to a well-worn playbook,
terrorize, expel and ethnically cleanse
the paramilitary rapid support forces.
RCF are currently engaged
in a fight
for dominance with Sudan's army.
But years
before that rivalry spilled blood
in Sudan's streets,
they were implicated
in atrocities in Darfur.
Now, once again,
Darfur to the west of the country
is stoked by the specter of genocide.
The damage wrought by these forces
so extensive,
you can see it from satellite images
This is Elgin, Ana West, Darfur.
Hundreds killed,
whole districts razed to the ground.
And it's not only angina that is burning.
This is under
and this could be a holy life
gotten out of official God
on the ground.
It looks like this.
These scenes sadly familiar in Darfur,
20 years ago,
the region descended into genocide.
The same RCF leadership in place
as their men killed Occupy and raped.
Now, once again, women's bodies
are part of the field of war.
We must warn you,
what you're about to see is shocking.
This video, filmed at great personal
risk, will show a girl
believed to be just 15 years old
being raped.
The ISF have threatened rape survivors
and denied their testimonies.
So we feel it necessary to broadcast
a small portion of this horrific assault.
You see here,
a man in light-colored fatigues
matching those worn by the ISF.
It's too awful to show in full.
But when the phone pans,
you see what he's guarding.
A man
wearing light
colored fatigues,
forcing himself onto the prone gun
CNN verified and geolocated
the area where this happened.
We're not revealing the exact location
in Khartoum to protect our sources.
And the young girl
This is not an isolated incident.
We received and reviewed dozens of cases
where women say they
were raped by RPF soldiers.
Identifying them by their
light colored fatigues
and the insignia
on their right shoulders.
So who is complicit in this pain?
Yes. Yes.
But the ISAF's key
ally, the notorious Russian
mercenary group
Wagner, has been sustaining their fight
and providing the impetus
to slaughter innocent people
by supplying arms.
We're going to show you how
this is an illusion.
76 cargo plane
operated by Virginia
sitting at a Libyan airbase.
A previous CNN investigation
exposed how this Russian cargo plane
was providing the ISAF
with deadly arms
from a Russian naval base
in Latakia, Syria,
via volunteer controlled bases in Libya.
This person starts
just days before the war begins in Sudan,
Libya, Syria and back.
And it picks up pace
what's interesting here
is the new focus on this issue,
where it goes
next, Bangui,
the capital of the Central
African Republic.
After our exposure of the Libya route,
a route
directly from the Central African
Republic into Darfur
became crucial for the ISF.
Eyewitnesses at
Key Transit Points and intelligence
active in the region
tells CNN
arms and supplies from this illusion
transported overland
using the truck captured here
and others like it
first to a Wagner base in Brazil
and then
in to south Darfur to an RAAF base
in Norfolk,
Virginia, putting their thumb
on the scales here
to secure access to Sudan's resources
through Darfur,
creating chaos and terror, helping tip
the balance of power
in their war in Ukraine,
whatever the cost.
And Nima Elbagir joins me now.
Nima, just an extraordinarily
harrowing report
as we've just seen,
the world has
been in a very similar moment
before watching the same forces
commit similar atrocities
in this very same area.
So what could the U.S.
and other countries be doing
Well, what we're hearing from
so many Sudanese is that the U.S.
could begin by using the correct language
until we shared our findings
with the State Department.
They had been referring
to these violent assaults and rapes
as the actions of armed actors,
even though
most of the recorded testimony
pointed directly to the RAAF.
And that has been a real cause
of fear for so many Sudanese
because they believe it.
It shows that the world doesn't
have the appetite
to hold the necessary actors accountable.
And you saw that in our reporting,
that it's not just about
what's happening in
Sudan, it's
about how this is going to impact US
national interests, global interests,
the war in Ukraine, Wagner continues.
Russian mercenaries continue
to sustain this fight
to allow them to exploit in the future
further Sudan's natural resources.
This is in no one's interest,
and I think that only further baffles
so many Sudanese
as to
why the US has not had
a stronger position.
And when I say baffles,
I'm white, I'm
not actually representing it accurately.
So many of those we're speaking to
are really heartbroken that the U.S.
and the international community
has not been able
has seen the
unwilling to do more to stop
what's being done to them.
And in the absence of that, Sudanese
like the ones who filmed that video.
A huge risk
of risking their lives to save themselves
and each other, Alex.
Huge risk
as Vegas presence continues to spread.
Nima Elbagir with her exclusive
reporting from inside Sudan.
Thank you very much
for sharing that with us.